hey chess fans sam copeland here
national master on the content team here
at chess.com
and i am here today to show you a
beautiful computer chess game
this game was played between komodo and
winter
winter is another engine that's stronger
than any human but it's not quite on the
level of stockfish and lila
and komodo there's a lot to appreciate
in this short game
particularly the spectacular finish
this game opens with e4 e5 knight f3
and now knight to f6 this is the russian
game
or petrov defense this opening is a
favorite of world championship
challenger
fabiano carawana however the opening is
not really known for chaos
and the kind of short and spectacular
victory that we are going to get here
in this position white can and does
capture on e5
knight takes e5 and now black must be a
little bit careful
it is not possible yet to capture on e4
white can play queen to e2 and after the
knight falls back
there is the move knight to c6 this move
is a check a discovered attack from the
queen
and the black queen is also under attack
white wins the game basically on the
spot
if you've never seen this before
definitely keep it in your memory
because you may have the chance to use
it and you definitely don't want to be a
victim to this trap
so instead black must be a little bit
more subtle
after white captures on e5 black can
play the move pawn
to d6 this pushes the white knight back
and now black
can capture on e4 if white tries queen
to e2 in this position then queen e7 is
totally okay for black
so in the game we get pawn to d4 here
and then pawn d5
bishop to d3 bishop to e7 castles
and knight to d6 now this is a
symmetrical position which means it's
one in which the pawn structure is the
same for both players
typically humans look at positions like
this and think drawish
it's going to be hard to create winning
chances in this kind of game
however computer engines are really good
at picking up on small details on the
position
and they often notice ways to pressure
in positions like this
for example black's knight on e4 has
lost some time as it's been hopping
around
because it doesn't want to get captured
on e4 it's ended up on the d6 square but
being on d6
is not really a happy place for that
knight it does get in the way of the
bishop on e7
on that square so after knight to d6 we
see the move rook to e1
castles for black c3 knight to d7
bishop to f4 rook to e8 knight b to d2
knight to f8 and knight to f1 both of
the players are completing the spanish
knight maneuver which
maneuvers the knight around to the king
side this is very common in e4 e5
positions
and it's often played when the knights
don't have really good prospects
on the c3 or c6 squares
so after knight to f1 we get to move
pawn to c6 and now
knight to e3 knight g6 the bishop is
attacked it falls back to g3 and the
knight hops back to e4
this knight is doing a lot of hopping
so in this position white tries to
undermine the knight on e4
with pawn to c4 i think the next move is
kind of a critical one
and winter makes a mistake probably
correct
is the move knight takes g3
after pawn takes g3 it is the case that
white should be
a little bit better but it's also the
case that white will really struggle to
win this game
instead winter makes a move that seems
very natural to move bishop b4
gaining a tempo and attacking the rook
on e1 and
opening up room for this rook on the 8
to be active and to support the knight
on e4
however after the move bishop to b4 and
rook to e2
we'll see that this rook is actually
very well placed
not inconvenienced at all by the
movement and the bishop on b4
is actually very very misplaced
so after rook to e2 we get to move
bishop to e6 and now pawn takes d5
now arguably black might like to take
back with the pawn and maintain the
symmetry in the position
but if you capture back with the pawn
the problem is the move
queen to b3 after queen to b3
it's clear that the bishop on b4 is
exposed and undefended
and there's also pressure against the
pawn on d5 and against the pawn on b7
this is very favorable for white and
another important detail is that the
rook moved to e2 which might have seemed
awkward
now allows the rook to quickly access
the c file and white may be able to
double rooks on the c file
and in general white has a big advantage
in this position
so after pawn takes d5 it's actually the
bishop that captures back
and now knight takes d5 and again you
don't want to take with the pawn
so queen takes d5 now white plays
a very nice move bishop to e5
this cuts off the rook on e8 and it
threatens the knight on e4
after the move knight takes e5 white
captures back with the knight
and now there are two threats in this
position the first threat is to capture
the knight on e4
pretty obvious the other threat is only
a little bit more subtle
it is the move bishop to c4 which will
attack the queen
and aim at the pawn on f7 only one move
defends against both threats it's the
move
knight to d6 now this
i think is a good position to pause for
a moment
and try to assess the position what
exactly is going on
from a human perspective it probably
doesn't seem like black is really any
worse at all
does white even have an advantage
however
if you dig deeper it's probably apparent
that white
is winning there are a couple of things
that i would point out
the first thing is the opposite colored
bishops
it's famously true in chess that
opposite colored bishops
favor the attacker whatever white
attacks with the light squared bishop
cannot be defended with black's dark
squared bishop the bishop
on b4 white can't access the square c4
but after the next move
bishop c2 the bishop inevitably reaches
b3 and it's going to take
aim against f7 that is a very very soft
point and this bishop is just a
spectator when it comes to trying to
defend that point
the other thing i would point out is
that black's pieces may look okay
but in fact they have real problems i
think the problems revolve
around the knight on d6 now that knight
is doing good defensive work it's
holding down the pawn on f7 and it
really needs to
but it's also getting in the way of the
rook that black would
would like to bring to the d8 square
that rook is going to come to d8 and
just be staring at this knight's behind
it is not going to be the lead sled dog
also the knight on d6 is getting in the
way of the bishop on b4 that bishop
might like to come back to d6
and it cannot in general that bishop is
stuck
on the queen side as we see things
develop
it quickly becomes apparent that these
advantages as well as the quick
inclusion of the heavy pieces in the
attack are decisive
in this position black plays the move
rook a to d8
now this move looks really really nice
however the rook again does absolutely
nothing as long as the knight is stuck
on d6
as we see the way the game goes it might
make sense to try to pull the queen back
instead and play the move queen to e6 so
that the queen is not stuck on the queen
side
however after bishop b3 queen f5 we have
a different problem after rook to e3
the rook is going to come to f3 and in
general trying to keep the queen on the
king side
is going to make her a target and the
rook will still be quickly included in
the attack
and again this is probably decisive
so after that rook 88 move we do see
bishop b3 and the queen is forced over
to the queen side
queen to b5 in this position rookie 3
is an excellent excellent rook lift and
it also allows the queen to enter the
attack
now you might try rookie 7 in this
position but queen g4
is another really strong move and among
many attacking ideas here
white has rook to g3 possibly including
a night sacrifice that leads quickly to
checkmate
so after rook to e3 we see the move
queen to a5 i really don't know what
this move does
but i don't have a better suggestion now
queen to h5 and there are huge attacks
here against f7
one defense here that looks tough for a
human to crack is the move
pawn to g6 and for a human this is
very difficult to beat but the computer
is quick to point out the white's
advantage is decisive
a human error that is very possible here
is the move knight takes g6
when yes if pawn takes queen takes looks
like a winning attack because of the pin
here
but the problem is that you've just hung
your queen all the way over here
on the fifth rank so after pawn to g6
white just plays the move
queen to h4 there are ideas like rook h3
here and they are very strong
king to g7 rook f3 and black can almost
almost save the game with knight to f5
in the face of the attacks on f6
and on f7 but white simply sacrifices
the exchange here
rook takes f5 and now after pawn takes
queen check and queen up to f6
this is a decisive attack there's just
no good way to defend against the mate
threatened here
white is all over the f7 square so
in the game we actually see the move
rook to e7
now i really want you to pause your
video try to play like komodo
and find the only immediately decisive
move
the checkmating move is queen
takes h7 check boom
this is immediately decisive
crushing and spectacular of course for a
human it is very
very easy to miss a move like this but
it is surprising that a computer engine
missed a forced checkmate in six
now after queen takes h7 king over
simply allows the immediate mate
so the king takes but after the rook
check here on the h file and the king
falls back
knight to g6 is beautiful
in this position the king cannot move
anywhere the knight cannot be captured
because of the pin here and black can
only give up the queen and after the
capture here you can give up the rook
and next move is mate with rook
2h8 this is a beautiful
beautiful beautiful checkmating
construction
now i hope that you've enjoyed this game
if you would like to see more amazing
computer chess games
then please click on the playlist that
is popping up right on top of your
screen